we shot a great majority of it uh on
location
um there there were there were stages
that we
used uh that were downtown los angeles
um
for a few of the sets but for the most
part yeah we were we were there
you know because we had to we had to
feel
we had to feel that the depth and the
breath you know of this world that she
was running through
in order to deal with the depth issue on
frame
was there any location that was i don't
know particularly difficult to lock or
if you didn't know you were going to get
approval to do it that made you say like
i
i need to be on location and i can't
recreate that anywhere else or
it's not going to work almost every
single one was difficult to walk
the la river you're not allowed to shoot
there anymore you know so we shot uh we
shot at a damn
um up in van nuys uh we
had to recreate uh the speakeasy
because real speakeasies are tiny
and um i needed you know i needed a lot
of depth
you know for the two characters as
they're escaping from carl e
to kind of move through a crowd and we
weren't getting that in the locations we
were seeing
as gorgeous as they were um the most
difficult location to shoot in
was the underground subway tunnels that
have been
abandoned for many years
and you feel the claustrophobia
of being under um
hundreds of stories of cement above you
when you're down there i mean all of us
had to wear masks
you know some people wearing you know
the gas masks to kind of filter out
uh and to feel like the city is above
you in an
earthquake kind of ridden city you know
we're the deepest you could ever
possibly go in los angeles in the earth
uh was was was not easy so we got in and
out of there as fast as we could we did
not even break the launch we said okay
let's get out
you